إذا كنت تعطس وتعاني من انسداد أو سيلان في
الأنف، فقد تكون مصابًا بنزلة برد أو
حساسية، ولن تساعد المضادات الحيوية
عادةً، فعادةً ما يستغرق الأمر بعض الوقت، لذا
يجب أن تستمر في رؤية التحسن بعد مرور 10 إلى 14 يومًا،
وبحلول ذلك الوقت نأمل أن تظهر
كل هذه الأعراض.  اختفى، في حين أن
الفينولين، وهو مكون في العديد من
أدوية البرد والحساسية الشائعة التي لا تستلزم وصفة طبية، اعتبر غير فعال
في تخفيف احتقان الأنف والأقراص
من قبل إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية. هناك طرق أخرى
لإزالة انسداد الأنف، كما تقول الدكتورة ساندرا هونغ
من كليفلاند كلينك أشياء مثل
يمكن أن تكون شطفات الملح مفيدة جدًا، ربما تكون قد
سمعت عن أوعية صافية،
حيث تستخدم فعليًا إما
الماء المغلي الذي تم تبريده أو الماء المقطر،
وعادةً ما يحتوي على ملح
وصودا الخبز لطرد
الجيوب الأنفية والأنف.  تقول هونغ إن مزيلات
الاحتقان الموضعية التي لا تستلزم وصفة طبية
يمكن أن تساعد أيضًا بشكل مؤقت، لكنها تقول
لا تستخدمها لفترة أطول من 3 إلى 5 أيام
لأنها يمكن أن تجعل احتقان الأنف
أسوأ، وتقول إن بخاخات الستيرويد الأنفية
ومضادات الهيستامين يمكن أن تساعد أيضًا، ولا
يزال هناك  مزيلات الاحتقان عن طريق الفم،
أشياء مثل سيدرين التي لا تستلزم
وصفة طبية، الشيء المتعلق بها هو
أنك بحاجة للذهاب والتحدث مع
الصيدلي الخاص بك للتوقيع على تلك الأدوية التي
يقول هونغ إنه على الرغم من أن هذه الأدوية
آمنة، إلا أنها يمكن أن يكون لها تأثير على أشياء
مثل ضغط الدم، لذا كن  تدرك
وتقول إذا لم تتحسن الأعراض
بمرور الوقت، تواصل مع طبيبك للحصول على
دقيقة صحية، أنا ماندي
جثر